bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de senna à
360 voici les titres vers une adoption
par le sénat de la loi bancaire mais
dans une version revue et corrigée les
sénateurs ont notamment supprimer le
regroupement écoles collèges critiqué
par les enseignants toujours mobilisés
contre ce texte ont manifesté cet après
midi devant le sénat le détail du vote
dans un instant les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement c'est à
suivre dans un quart d'heure et
l'exécutif va devoir répondre aux
interrogations suscitées par les couacs
et de parcours ce hub pour le sénateur
caruso gas le gouvernement a fait du
surbooking
vous l'entendrez dans cette émission
coup de théâtre dans la sphère vincent
lambert hier soir la cour d'appel de
paris a accédé à la demande des parents
de cette et rappeler gic en état
végétatif depuis 11 ans demandant la
reprise des traitements alors que les
soins avaient été suspendus le matin les
réactions au sénat à suivre et je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez réagir à cette
édition sur twitter avec le hashtag
sénat 360 pour m'accompagner
cet après midi on retrouvera tam tran
huy en direct de la salle des
conférences et alexandre poussard depuis
l'hémicycle du sénat le multiplex
parlementaire s'est tout de suite
sur lisez en titre les sénateurs
s'apprêtent à voter définitivement le
projet de loi pour une école de la
confiance défendue par le ministre jean
michel leblanc caire mais dans une
version largement modifié par la haute
assemblée
si les sénateurs ont supprimé l'article
qui faisait la polémique sur le
regroupement d'écoles primaires avec des
collèges ils ont en revanche apporté de
nouvelles modifications
samia de sheer le sénat reste opposé à
la fusion écoles primaires et collèges
supprimée en commission cette mesure de
la loi bancaire est revenu dans
l'hémicycle par un amendement du
sénateur et l'ère jacques grosperrin il
proposé d'ajouter des garanties comme le
maintien d'un directeur par site ou
l'accord des collectivités territoriales
concernées pour toute modification de
l'implantation des classes pas suffisant
pour apaiser les tensions après des mois
de polémique a jugé le ministre de
l'éducation
je ne peux que constater les malentendus
qui se sont installés autour de cette
idée il n'y aurait rien de pire que de
l'abîmé au travers de d'un malentendu
donc nous avons clairement le sentiment
qui a besoin de temps de maturation et
s'agissant de cet amendement je dirai à
mon tour sagesse
la commission de la culture et de
l'éducation a elle aussi émis un avis de
sagesse cela veut dire qu'elle ne se
prononce pas il s'en remet au vote des
sénateurs et les sénateurs ont été
nombreux à s'y opposer
cela partait d'un texte à l'origine qui
était une erreur
pour ne pas dire et d'une connerie est
une connerie même réécrite
c'est un peu meilleure mais c'est pas
beaucoup mieux
vous ne vouliez pas de bois blanc coeur
écoutez vous aurez loi blanquet rhin et
je vous invite rapidement à déposer une
loi blank r2 donc revenez avec un second
texte et traitons enfin tous ces sujets
mais après la plus vaste concertation
possible devant les nombreux appels à
voter contre
jacques grosperrin a finalement retiré
son amendement la fusion écoles
primaires et collèges est donc supprimée
du texte par les sénateurs pas opposé
sur le fond il réclame d'abord une
concertation des acteurs concernés
voilà et le vote vient d'intervenir le
sénat donc adopter ce projet de loi pour
en parler on retrouve alexandre poussin
depuis la tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle
woods est le film senna vient à
l'instant d'adopter ce projet de loi
pour une école de la confiance on
l'entend jean michel blanquer
qui est tu applaudis par l'hémicycle du
sénat il réagi au vote sur ce texte le
sénat a donc adopté avec 213 voix pour
ce projet de loi et il ya eu 95 voix
contre alors même si la droite du sénat
a adopté un texte modifié sensiblement
on l'a vu lors des explications de vote
cet après midi le discours du sénateur
jacques grosperrin au nom du groupe
l'est républicain a été très dur envers
le texte de jean michel blanquer r la
droite sénatoriale considère que c'est
un texte qui est avant tout un outil de
communication avec des mesures
cosmétiques comme l'école obligatoire à
3 ans alors que déjà 97 % des enfants
sont scolarisés à cette ag pu également
avec la formation rendu obligatoire
entre 16 et 18 ans or du côté de la
gauche du sénat qui n'a pas voté pour ce
projet google
on regrette certaines mesures ajoutées
par la droite du sénat notamment la
suspension des allocations familiales
pour lutter contre l'absentéisme de
certains élèves
et puis les sénateurs communistes
dénoncent un texte qui renforce une
école à deux vitesses du côté du groupe
la république en marche au sénat et bien
on s'est abstenu un dessinateur et l'om
qui espère que sénateurs et députés
s'entendre sur une version commune de ce
texte lors de la commission mixte
paritaire
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes vos
précisions nouveau coup de théâtre dans
la sphère vincent lambert
quelques heures après l'arrêt des soins
qui maintiennent en vie cet homme on
était avérée et hâtifs depuis 2008 la
cour d'appel de paris saisie par ses
parents a ordonné à la surprise générale
la reprise des traitements décision qui
relance une nouvelle fois le débat
juridique sur la fin de vie adrien
devenait en plein coeur de paris lundi
soir
des cris de joie
la cour d'appel vient d'ordonner la
reprise du traitement de vincent lambert
pour ses partisans du maintien des soins
c'est une victoire des mesures
conservatoires à savoir que
l'alimentation et l'hydratation de
vincent en pleurs doit être reprise sans
délai depuis 9h30 le même jour vincent
lambert ne recevait plus le traitement
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
a rejeté la demande de maintien des
soins le matin même mais la cour d'appel
de paris en a décidé autrement
une décision provisoire selon les juges
prises pour permettre au comité des
droits des personnes handicapées de
l'onu d'étudier le dossier
suite à une demande des parents du
patient après ce nouveau rebondissement
les membres de la famille pour l'arrêt
des soins comme le neveu de vincent
lambert espère que l'hôpital où l'état
va se pourvoir en cassation est
légalement jusqu'à ce que fait la cour
d'appel de paris c'est très discutable
le prouve en cassation c'est le chu de
reims qui peut le faire non à d'autres
procédures éventuellement envisageable
voilà six ans que les procédures
judiciaires ont commencé c'est une
bataille sans fin qui oppose les membres
de la famille un partisan du maintien
des soins palliatifs et ceux qui
souhaitent leur arrêt dès 2014 le
conseil d'état avait donné son feu vert
à l'arrêt des soins qui maintiennent en
vie l'homme plongée dans un état
végétatif depuis 11 ans puis en 2017
c'est le conseil constitutionnel qui
rendait à son tour un avis favorable
les nouvelles procédures risquent de
durer encore plusieurs mois avec un
million c'est le président de la
commission au sénat
oui elle un million comment réagissez
vous à ce nouveau rebondissement dans la
sphère vincent lambert alors que la cour
d'appel de paris a donc demandé à ce que
les traitements 1 reprennent alors
qu'ils avaient été arrêtés hier disputé
moi d'abord ma première réaction c'est
de me dire que je n'aimerais pas être à
la place de la famille qui continue
souffrir qu'ils continuent de se battre
entre eux et c'est une situation qui est
particulièrement
dramatique ensuite je n'aimerais pas
être à la place non plus de l'équipe
soignante parce que je suis persuadé que
celle ci a fait tout ce qu'il fallait
pour essayer de maintenir vincent
lambert en vie pour essayer de sortir de
ce coma dans lequel il se trouve et qui
subit actuellement la pression
médiatique et populaire considérable qui
ne devrait pas être pour une équipe de
santé enfin je voudrais dire aussi que
il ya une décision de justice
derrière des injustices qui va à
l'encontre des intentions de justice
mais comme tout les 0 6 ans justice
doivent être respectées par les
politiques mais c'est compliqué a
effectivement quand les décisions de
justice vont à l'encontre les unes des
autres pour vous est-ce que vous jugez
qu'on est dans un cas d'obstination
déraisonnable au tel qu'il est défini
par la laque loin claisse leonetti de
2016 et que donc pas ce qu'avait pu
disent être décidées a auparavant
l'arrêt des traitements et mairie juste
la loi que les gones et y prévoit donc
le cas d'obstination déraisonnable
est ce que nous on est dans le cadre
d'une obstination déraisonnable l'équipe
soignante le dit en tout cas
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est connaître un
peu mieux le dossier médical de vincent
lambert savoir si son ami trois sépales
hogra nos plats s'il ya plus de
réactions s'il n'y a aucune chance de
avec un électroencéphalogramme plat de
revenir n'y a pas de raison de continuer
maintenant la loi léonetti claisse
prévoit aussi des directives anticipées
là il y en a pas et c'est dommage et
bien tout le problème
c'est tout le problème et puis pour vous
il faut les rendre obligatoire ces
directives anticipées à la vue de cette
affaire il me semble que ce serait bien
que chacun puisse être en effet obligé
de donner à un temps donné ses
directives anticipées quitte à les
changer dans le temps au fur et à mesure
de son évolution dans le cadre de ce
sujet là et puis la loi l'occasion et
qui prévoit aussi et surtout des soins
palliatifs sur l'ensemble du territoire
y compris des soins palliatifs à
domicile on y est très loin encore ça se
développe c'est long c'est extrêmement
coûteux mais je pense que quand on aura
fait cela on aura fait l'essentiel en
tout cas ce que j'aimerais dans la
mesure où on a une famille qui souffre
une équipe soignante qui souffrent c'est
que les politiques se mêlent pas trop de
ça oui justement le jour est votre
réaction à ce que dit la tête de liste l
air aux européennes françois xavier
bellamy se dit lui heureux de la reprise
des soins que pensez-vous des maires du
fait qu'il ait pris ainsi partagé que je
ne partage pas son bonheur oui vous
trouvez qu effectivement ce n'est pas
mieux pour les politiques de se
prononcer vraiment pas aux politiques de
se prononcer sur un sujet comme celui à
qui est un sujet médical d'abord
familiale ensuite est légal dans le cas
de la loi classe leonetti toute dernière
question à un million sur tout autre
chose autour du fichage de gilet jaune
avec le président de la commission des
lois vous avez demandé à la ministre de
s'expliquer ou est-ce que vous en êtes
on n'a pas demandé à nous expliquer on a
écrit on a fait un courrier à un
ministre
donc elle n'a évidemment un temps pour
répondre j'espère que comme il y a deux
présidents qui ont écrit qu'elle
répondra aux deux présidents et dès
qu'on aura la réponse on vous le fera
savoir eh bien merci beaucoup alain
milon d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup avait justement vous
venez d'en parler avec votre invité y
aura-t-il une commission denquête au
sénat sur le fichage des gilets jaunes
les sénateurs exigent des explications
de la part d'anne et abusant la ministre
de la santé après les révélations sur
l'utilisation du fichier est civil c'est
pour systèmes d'information pour le
suivi des victimes il y avait été mise
en place pour des blessés admis aux
urgences lors de manifestations gilet
jaune flora sauvage des gilet jaune
hospitalisé font ils l'objet d'un
fichage illicite par les hôpitaux
parisiens
comme l'a révélé le canard enchaîné le
fichier civique le système d'information
pour le suivi des victimes
instaurée suite aux attentats de 2015 a
été utilisé dans le cadre des
manifestations des gilets jaunes dans la
capitale dans un courrier adressé à
agnès buzyn la ministre de la santé le
président de la commission des lois et
celui de la commission des affaires
sociales veulent faire la lumière sur la
réalité du recueil de données leurs
admissions hospitalières consécutive à
des manifestations sur la voie publique
dont l'exploitation est susceptible de
porter atteinte à la liberté
individuelle
notre démarche est une démarche
constructive compte tenu de l'émotion
qui a eu lieu et du fait que le sénat a
toujours eu dans son histoire sa longue
histoire
la vocation d'être le défenseur des
droits individuels du secret de la vie
privée et des libertés publiques
dans l'opposition on dénonce une
violation grave du secret professionnel
nous avons des interrogations sur la
confidentialité des données de santé
les données de santé sont un marché
économique et ont aussi une sensibilité
personnelle et peuvent avoir une
utilisation politique donc il faut être
très clair il faut que nos concitoyens
aient confiance et la confiance ça
nécessite la transparence or là l'ap-hp
a fauté par manque de transparence et ne
nous dit pas la vérité sans réponse
satisfaisante de la ministre de la santé
les sénateurs se laisse la possibilité
de mettre en place une commission d'
enquête et ont continué leurs actions au
niveau interne tran huy avec le sénateur
socialiste de saône et loire jean burin
oui jérôme durera le sauna demandons des
explications à agnès buzyn sur le
fichage de gilet jaune quel problème
suspects et vous écouter il ya quand
même un mélange des genres qui est quand
même inquiétant
mon collègue bernard joly a posé une
question fort pertinente la semaine
dernière à la ministre
la réponse elle ne l'était pas
pertinente puisque on a rien compris et
que visiblement tout le monde est bien
embêté avec cette affaire l'ap-hp qui a
quand même diligenté une enquête
la ministre avec une enquête de la rs et
aux fonds comprend pas pourquoi un
fichier comme celui là qui n'a rien à
voir avec le fichage de tel ou tel
individu a été dévoyée de la sorte
oui on rappelle que sans médecin on tape
là ne plus renseigné ce fichier le
fichier civique c'est une procédure
exceptionnelle en cas d'afflux
exceptionnel et juge qu'il a été
détourné de sa fonction première
finalement avec le mouvement des gilet
jaune
visiblement quand même il ya une forme
d'altération des libertés publiques sur
un certain nombre de sujets en violation
du secret médical à une violation du
secret médical mais les gilets jaunes
ont été le révélateur d'une manière
générale dans le champ de libertés
publiques d'un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements ça a été vraiment en
matière de sécurité lors de
manifestations ça a été vrai sur
d'autres sujets et là on voit que en
matière médicale
on a aussi eu un petit souci donc ça
finit par faire beaucoup et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on aille au bout des
explications qui pour l'instant restent
très très peu explicite vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs une enquête interne a été
diligentée est-ce que vous pourquoi ne
pas attendre le résultat de cette
enquête interne
de demander des comptes à la ministre
mon collègue bernard jaume y avait la
semaine dernière une une très bonne
formule il disait c'est quand même pas
celui qui commet une infraction d'aller
vérifier la nature de l'infraction et je
pense qu'un peu d'indépendance sur ce
sujet ferait du bien à notre démocratie
et au dossier en l'espèce c'est un peu
je crois le sens des interpellations qui
ont été exprimées par le président de la
commission des lois et président de la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat
est-ce que vous même vous envisagez déjà
une commission d' enquête autour du
fichage des gilet jaune ou bien c'est
seulement si vous n'obtenez pas mais
justement une réponse satisfaisante de
la part du ministère le sénat
notre chambre haute et la chambre des
libertés on n'a pas non plus vocation à
produire de la commission denquête au
kilomètre ce qu'on veut c'est des
répondants pour l'instant sur la version
n'est pas encore on n'y est pas encore
il faut des réponses pour l'instant le
compte n'y est pas donc on attend les
réponses et puis après on verra pour
rien s'interdire
est ce que cela peut aussi entraîner par
la suite des craintes autres sur
l'utilisation des données médicales des
personnes on sait bien on va vers le
dossier médical partagé et ses skis puis
avoir des craintes à l'avenir qui ceux
qui vont plus loin pour vous non je ne
crois pas qu'il faille inférées de ses
difficultés sur ce fichier particulier
ce dossier particulier d'autres craintes
au delà
en revanche je pense que certains
responsables de l'ap-hp aurait mieux
fait de garder le silence c'était pas la
peine d'aller crier au loup sur
l'intrusion peut-être pour dissimuler
d'autres soucis avec les fichiers oui
vous jugez que justement l'ap-hp a quand
même joué un rôle trouble dans toute
cette gestion aujourd'hui en tout cas je
suis aussi ces troubles mais c'était pas
très pas très heureux et pas très bien
aspirés bien merci à beaucoup jérôme
durain d'avoir répondu à mes questions
et nous allons donc rejoindre dans un
instant alexandre poussard qui est nous
attend justement dans l'hémicycle bien
pour savoir à bien l'ordre du jour de
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement alexandre alors qu' il faut
le dire aussi et bien la loi pour
l'école de la confiance vient d'être
adoptée dans l'hémicycle nuitamment
cette séance de questions d'actualité
qui succède à l'instant au vote et à
l'adoption par le sénat de ce projet de
loi pour une école de la confiance alors
quel va être le menu de cette séance de
questions d'actualité du sénat au
gouvernement
eh bien on va parler de parcours sup la
plateforme d'orientation des lycéens
vers l'enseignement supérieur juste
après le baccalauréat et cette
plateforme parcours sup
elle a connu un grave dysfonctionnement
la semaine dernière puisque des dizaines
de milliers de lycéens ont d'abord reçu
des réponses positives d'admission dans
certaines filières dans certaines
formations d'enseignement supérieur
avant finalement d'essuyer un refus de
la part de ces formations d'où la grande
déception de ses lycéens
la miss va être interrogé par deux
sénateurs un communiste un les
républicains la cause vient de sonner
c'est le début de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
monsieur le premier ministre a prié de
l'excusé de ne pouvoir assister à cette
séance de questions au gouvernement je
vous rappelle que notre science et
retransmise en direct sur public sénat
sur notre site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect des uns
des autres et en même temps au temps de
la parole la parole
et pour pierre ouzoulias ce pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes avaient la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
plusieurs milliers de candidats qui
avaient reçu une réponse favorable de
parcours suppl soir se sont réveillés le
matin avec un avis négatif
madame la ministre vous expliquer ce
dysfonctionnement qui toucherait 7% des
candidats par un problème d'informatique
pourtant dans un premier temps vos
services ont incité est autorisé par
écrit les établissements à pratiquer un
taux de sur réservation jusqu'à 50% dans
un second temps vous les avez autorisé à
dépasser ce taux alors pourquoi cette
panique et surtout pourquoi reporter sur
les établissements la responsabilité
d'un revirement qui la conséquence de
vos décisions politiques que vous
n'assumez pas en janvier le défenseur
des droits vous avez demandé de rendre
publics les critères de sélection des
établissements et de réformer parcours
sub pour mettre fin aux discriminations
subies par les lycéens des filières
technologiques et professionnelles
nous attendons toujours vos réponses à
ces questions essentielles
madame la ministre
pour vous répondre la parole l'état la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche d'innovation madame
frédéric vidal j'avais la barre haut
merci monsieur le président mesdames
dessinatrice messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur aux elias merci de
votre question qui va permettre de
préciser les choses je n'ai jamais parlé
d'un problème informatique
j'ai simplement indiqué que 2% des
formations s'étaient trompés lorsqu'elle
avait de façon manuelle saisi le nombre
de candidats sur la liste d'appels c'est
une erreur humaine c'est une erreur
factuelle
c'est une erreur qui évidemment est
extrêmement regrettable et c'est
pourquoi j'ai aussi demandé à
l'inspection générale de regarder les
raisons précises qui explique ces
erreurs de façon à ce qu'elles ne
puissent pas se reproduire
l'autre sujet auquel vous faites
référence est un sujet qui est
totalement différent
rappelez vous l'été dernier un certain
nombre d'entre vous sur ces bancs comme
à l'assemblée nationale
indiquez la crainte qu avait un certain
nombre d'établissements et notamment les
classes préparatoires de ne pas remplir
leur formation à cause de la mise en
place de parcours sub c'est pourquoi en
accord avec ces établissements nous leur
avons proposé de pouvoir avoir ce taux
d'appels légèrement supérieur mais là
nous parlons de tout autre chose
monsieur olias puisque il s'agit en
réalité de formation qui avait 30 places
disponibles et qui ont appelé 600
candidats il s'agit selon bien
malheureusement d'une erreur humaine et
d'une erreur matérielle
le service qui permet de surveiller le
fonctionnement de la plateforme a
immédiatement relevé ces anomalies et
les établissements eux mêmes ont appelé
le ministère en nous disant nous avons
fait des erreurs aidez nous à les
corriger ma responsabilité c'est de
faire en sorte que ces erreurs qui
affectait 2% des formations bien
n'impacte pas les 900 mille candidats et
donc la procédure a pu poursuivre son
cours normalement avec quelques heures
de retard ce qui nous permet d'avoir
aujourd'hui 72% des lycéens qui ont
d'ores et déjà une proposition
d'affectation pour la rentrée
universitaire je remercie
tiounov madame la v10 je doute
sincèrement que les candidats les
parents soient rassurés par la clarté de
vos explications pour le moins en ce qui
nous concerne nous continuerons à
dénoncer la violence de ce dispositif
qui l'an passé a éloigné de
l'enseignement supérieur plus de 180
mille lycéens
nous continuerons de défendre un
enseignement supérieur accessible à tous
les bacheliers sans discrimination le
bug de parcours sup n'est pas
informatique madame la ministre le bug
de parcours sup il est social
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue nicole bonnefoy pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture le
11 avril dernier la justice
reconnaissait monsanto responsable du
dommage causé à l'agriculteur paul
françois victime du lasso un puissant
herbicide
il ya quelques jours aux états unis
monsanto était de nouveau condamné à
indemniser les victimes du roundup
depuis près de deux ans le groupe
socialiste du sénat demande avec
insistance la création d'un fonds des
manises à sion pour les victimes des
produits phytosanitaires et depuis près
de deux ans le gouvernement refuse cette
création
en effet le 1er février 2018 nous
votions ici au sénat à l'unanimité et
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
alors sur nos bancs le voter la création
de ce fonds d'indemnisation nous
formulions à nouveau cette demande dans
le projet de loi et galim mais votre
prédécesseur l'a rejetée en décembre
dernier ce fut à votre tour en tant que
ministre cette fois de la rejeter
également lors la loi de finances pour
2010 9
nous sommes en mai 2010 9 et 18 mois
après l'adoption par le sénat de notre
proposition de loi rien n'a avancé
même votre promesse de remise d'un
rapport au 30 avril 2019 n'a pas été
honorée rapport pourtant inutile car
vous le savez redondant avec les travaux
de l'inserm en 2013 de l'inde
500 2016 et des trois inspections
générales en 2018
à cela il faut rajouter le récent
rapport de l'onu sur l'état de la
biodiversité ou encore le récent
scandale monsanto avec ces pratiques de
lobbying insupportable monsieur le
ministre pour toutes ces raisons il est
temps de sortir du déni politique du
déni industrielle en faisant en sorte
que les grandes firmes prennent et
assume toute la responsabilité
c'est comme cela aussi que nous
changeront durablement les pratiques ma
question est donc celle ci parce que les
malades attendent souffrent et sont
livrés à eux mêmes quand précisément ce
fondane anisation verra-t-il le jour
prendre la parole et à madame la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame agnès buzyn j'avais la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs dessinateur madame la
sénatrice nicole bonnefoy
d'abord je voudrais commencer par saluer
le travail des parlementaires qui sont
engagés sur ce sujet que ce soit à
l'assemblée nationale où ici au sénat
plusieurs mesures vous le savez ont déjà
permis de réduire l'utilisation des
produits phytosanitaires avec françois
de rugy fait avec zidane et didier
guillon nous avons installé
officiellement le 10 avril dernier le
comité d'orientation stratégique et de
suivi du plan national de réduction des
produits phytosanitaires
s'agissant de la création du fonds
d'indemnisation des victimes des
produits phytopharmaceutiques
il convient d'être juste et attentif à
la souffrance des victimes
il convient aussi d'être responsables en
mettant en place un dispositif
d'indemnisation en cohérence avec les
connaissances scientifiques
nous attendons les rapports vous l'avez
dit mais également en lien avec les voix
d'indemnisation qui existent déjà
aujourd'hui en particulier dans le cadre
des accidents du travail et des maladies
professionnelles
lors de l'examen de la proposition loi
l'assemblée en janvier dernier j'ai
proposé que les discussions reprennent
dans le cadre de l'examen des lois de
finances ou à l'occasion de la poursuite
de l'examen de la proposition de loin
j'ai pris l'engagement qui figurent des
articles tendant à créer ce fond sur la
base des discussions qui ont eu lieu
lors de l'examen de votre proposition de
loin en attendant un rapport sur le
financement et les modalités de création
d'un fonds d'indemnisation doit vous
être rendu
j'ai souhaité que ce délai de quelques
mois soit mis à profit pour travailler
avec le ministère de l'agriculture et 10
des grilles guillaume sur le financement
du fonds
le rapport devrait vous être remis d'ici
la fin du mois de juin
j'invite donc tous les parlementaires à
rester mobilisés et nous aurons
l'occasion de débattre à nouveau encore
ensemble cette année sur le sujet je
vous remercie madame à deux fois wii
minna no merci de rappeler le travail
important qui a été réalisé en
particulier au sénat sur cette question
le rapport nous entendons qui sera remis
fin juin donc ne l'attendons avec
impatience bien évidemment vous évoquez
la future loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale pour la création du fonds nous
serons particulièrement vigilants sur la
création de ce fonds concernant son
périmètre en particulier et les
modalités de sa mise en oeuvre qui sont
importantes et nous regrettons cependant
d'avoir perdu deux ans sur la création
de ce fonds est effectif merci la parole
est au président claude malhuret
pour le groupe les indépendants monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre il ya
quelques mois un rapport en mal de
notoriété a commis un clip intitulé
pendez les blancs quelques phrases ce
chef-d'oeuvre je rentre dans des crèches
je tue des bébés blanc attrapé l'éviter
pendait leurs parents écartelé les pour
passer le temps sur plainte du ministre
de l'intérieur ce grand artiste a été
condamné à une amende avec sursis
dans ces conditions pourquoi se priver
nick conrad c'est son nom a donc
récidivé ces jours ci avec un nouvel
opus d'aussi haut niveau je baise la
france jusqu'à l'agonie je brûle la
france je vais poser une bombe sous son
panthéon à la fin du clip il étrangle en
gros plan une femme blanche
le ministre de l'intérieur a porté
plainte immédiatement il a eu raison
mais avec la loi actuelle l'auteur sera
condamnée dans deux ans à une peine
légère
entre temps le clip aura été vu quelques
millions de fois
le racisme n'est qu'une des plaies
béantes des réseaux dits sociaux et le
racisme anti blanc n'est pas plus
tolérable qu'un autre les autres plaies
s'appelle sexisme intimidations
usurpation d'identité harcèlement
injures et menaces de mort les gaffes à
fond le service minimum pour conserver
leur business
ce mais mark zuckerberg a dû convenir
lui-même qu'il n'avait pas les moyens de
réguler efficacement ses plateformes et
n'a rien trouvé de mieux que d'appeler
les gouvernements à légiférer
il est urgent de le prendre au mot les
allemands n'ont pas hésité à faire une
loi ordonnant le retrait de contenus
haineux sous 24
qu'attendons nous pour les imiter une
proposition de loi est en préparation
nous dit on à l'assemblée nationale je
voudrais être sûr monsieur le ministre
que le gouvernement ne l'accueillera pas
d'une main tremblante il ne s'agit pas
de liberté d'opinion et de censure il
s'agit de lutter contre des délits
graves le plus souvent commis
anonymement
il me semble même que le sujet est
tellement grave qu'il justifierait un
débat national et une unité européenne
aujourd'hui balbutiante la haine ou le
racisme n'ont pas leur place chez nous
nous ne sommes pas au far west et même
dans la jungle
il y à une loi qui est urgent de faire
respecter les nôtres merci merci
monsieur le président la parole et au
secrétaire d'état en charge du numérique
monsieur cédric tome sioniste merci
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs le sénateur monsieur le
président malhuret je vous remercie de
m'interroger siens qui fusaient qui je
crois appel profondément une obligation
de résultats de la part de l'état vous
avez cité un cas particulier mais au
delà se compare donc constate tous les
jours c'est que aujourd'hui on peut
impunément injurié menacé et même aller
encore plus loin sur internet
cela appelle vous avez raison une
mobilisation générale c'est ce qu'a
commencé à faire le président de la
république avec la première ministre néo
zélandaise la semaine dernière en
mettant autour de la table tous les
réseaux sociaux afin de prendre des
premières mesures d'urgence c'est ce que
fait la députée laetitia via vous l'avez
cité tout à l'heure en déposant sa
proposition de loi afin de réguler les
messages de haine de racisme
d'antisémitisme d'homophobie sur
internet et je peux vous assuré monsieur
le député que le président le
gouvernement
a parfaitement travaillé avec la députée
et que nous accueillons ces propositions
avec beaucoup de bienveillance
plus globalement je crois monsieur le
député que la question vous causez et
vous l'avez sur le sénateur je prie la
haute assemblée de dect accepté mes
excuses à monsieur le sénateur que le
sujet que vous posez est profondément
européen car pour imposer notre loi et
nos valeurs aux réseaux sociaux
alors nous ne serons pas trop de 400
millions d'européens et d'un marché qui
nous permet d'imposer nos valeurs et de
protéger nos citoyens c'est ce que nous
avons déjà fait sur la vie privée avec
le règlement général de protection des
données
c'est ce que nous avons fait sur le
terrorisme puisque aujourd'hui les
plateformes devons retirer en moins
d'une heure les contenus à caractère
terroriste
mais nous devons aller encore plus loin
vous avez raison est allé chercher ses
contenus monsieur le sénateur qui sont
aujourd'hui absolument inacceptable sur
les contenus haineux sur le terrorisme
sur la pédopornographie
nous devons aller plus loin et unir nos
actions avec nos partenaires européens
car sur ce sujet sans union pas de
protection efficace des français et des
européens donner de la force de
protection monsieur le sénateur c'est
aussi cela l'enjeu écologique du
week-end prochain
merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
bernard fournier pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je
voudrais évoquer avec vous la situation
de vincent lambert et le des braques
comme l'émoi qu'il suscite dans le pays
et je veux le faire sans céder aux
tentations qui dans cette affaire peut
tous nous guetter quelles que soient nos
convictions intimes celle des postures
établi davance des certitudes tout fait
devant une telle situation ayons
l'humilité ou plutôt l'humanité de
compatir et l'humilité de reconnaître
compatir parce qu'au delà des positions
des uns ou des autres
il y à un drame il ya le silence d'un
homme il y à la douleur des chants d'une
famille déchirée exposés sur la place
publique
il ya aussi la détresse d'une épouse et
l'espérance d'une mère reconnaître car
reconnaissons que ni le droit ni la
médecine ne nous offrent des réponses
at-il indiscutable l'institution
médicale est divisée quant à
l'institution judiciaire
l'arrêt rendu hier soir par la cour
d'appel de paris démontrent que sur le
plan du droit également des
interrogations demeurent
alors si croire que croire il n'ya pas
me choque avec deux certitudes qui c'est
ici dans cet hémicycle ce que veut
vincent lambert qui pouvait affirmer
savoir ce qu'est les médecins eux mêmes
ne savent pas ayons la force d'esprit et
de coeur d'admettre que nous ne savons
pas peut-être devrions-nous nous
interroger avec humilité sur les deux
questions fondamentales que je vous pose
ma mère les ministres d'abord jusqu'où
pouvons nous considérer qu'une vie ne
vaut plus la peine d'être vécue
et puis enfin l'incertitude le doute
elle des décisions parfois
contradictoires dans cette terrible
affaire font craindre à beaucoup de
français le risque d'une dérive
préjudiciable aux plus fragiles une
sorte d' insécurité éthiques
ne faut-il pas ma derniers ministres
tirer dès à présent sur les leçons de ce
drame je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole et à la bhl madame la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bernard fournier je crois
pouvoir dire que comme beaucoup de
français nous sommes tous nombreux ici à
être bouleversés par cette situation par
ce drame familial elle touche à l'intimé
de chacun d'entre nous vous le savez
l'état français a toujours été soucieux
de s'assurer que l'application de la
procédure d'arrêt de traitement en cas
d'obstination déraisonnable respectait
le cadre de la loi claisse leonetti
voter en 2016 hier soir la cour d'appel
de paris a accepté la requête des
parents de vincent humbert et a ordonné
la reprise des traitements afin de faire
exécuter les recommandations du comité
des droits des personnes handicapées de
l'onu l'équipe médicale en charge de
vincent lambert appliquera ces mesures
provisoires
je n'en dirai pas davantage sur ce cas
particulier
aujourd'hui encore plus que jamais nous
devons respecter l'intimité la douleur
de la famille et des proches de vincent
lambert
la seule leçon que nous pouvons retenir
de cette situation est que chacun
remplisse ses directives d'anticiper
chaque personne majeure peut depuis la
loi claisse leonetti de 2016
rédigé par avance une déclaration pour
préciser ses volontés en fin de vie
chacun peut inscrire son refus ou sa
volonté de poursuivre de limiter ou
d'arrêter les traitements ou les actes
médicaux les consignes données dans les
directives anticipées permettent aux
équipes médicales de prendre en charge
les patients en reste
tant leur propre volonté ces directives
anticipées
on peut les remplir sur internet elles
sont également accessibles dans le
dossier médical partagé
j'engage chaque français aujourd'hui
aller à les renseigner
je vous remercie merci la mini la parole
est maintenant madame la présidente
catherine morin desailly pour le groupe
de l'union centriste avait la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
président de la république a rencontré
mark zuckerberg et a annoncé des mesures
sur la régulation des réseaux sociaux
celles ci font suite à une mission
effectuée auprès de facebook
le rapport publié ce mois-ci a été
saluée par l'entreprise comme un modèle
pour la régulation des contenus en
europe
ces mesures prône une simple
co-régulation de ses plateformes
surprenant très surprenant au moment où
des voix s'élèvent des deux côtés de
l'atlantique pour dire l'impossibilité
d'une auto ou d'une co régulation de
cette société la sénatrice américaine
elizabeth world ou encore chris young un
des cofondateurs de facebook allant lui
même jusqu'à réclamer le démantèlement
de facebook
ce rapport est vide soigneusement
d'aborder la question du modèle
économique de cette société à moitié
étonnant émanant pour partie d'un
certain benoît loutrel ancien directeur
de l'ars septe un temps parti vendre ses
services à google puis revenue au coeur
de l'appareil d'état mais très
regrettable si l'on considère les graves
dérives éthiques économiques et
politiques dont s'est rendu coupable
facebook avec l'entreprise cambridge
analytique a affaire à laquelle a été
lié un certain steve banane il est
illusoire de penser que la société peut
remettre elle-même en cause son propre
modèle basé sur toujours plus de données
collectées est donc toujours plus de
biens mais question sont donc simples
compte tenu des enjeux pour la
souveraineté de la france quelles
mesures comptez vous prendre pour mettre
un terme à ces pratiques régulières de
pantouflage puis de reto pauvres où la
jeunesse haute administration notamment
avec les gars femmes n'est-il pas temps
de sortir la complaisance pour prendre
des mesures de régulation réellement
contraignant sur le coeur même de
l'activité de ces sociétés comme annonce
vouloir le faire d'ailleurs nos voisins
allemands toujours plus lucide et
exigeant que nous
depuis toujours sur les sujets pour vous
répondre la parole et secrétaire d'état
chargé du numérique
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la présidente mme morin dessailly
l'hébergeur l'émergence d'acteurs de la
taille qui est celle de google ou
facebook ou encore amazon pose des
enjeux absolument inédit à la puissance
publique est dit car la taille des
acteurs est inédite
facebook c'est 2,3 milliards
d'utilisateurs inédit car le numérique
ne connaît pas par nature deux
frontières et inédite car la complexité
technologique des outils de ses acteurs
et sans cesse croissante pour autant et
vous l'avez précisé les questions posées
par ces acteurs sont très concrètes et
impacte nos concitoyens dans leur
quotidien et je suis persuadé d'une
chose madame la sénatrice c'est que
l'émergence de ces acteurs appellent une
obligation de résultat aux démocraties
pour une raison simple c'est que si les
seuls états qui savent efficacement
réguler les grands acteurs de l'internet
réseaux sociaux et plateformes sont les
acteurs autoritaire où les pouvoirs
autoritaires
alors nos citoyens se tourneront vers
des solutions autoritaires
encore faut-il un à mme la sénatrice
madame la présidente que nos citoyens
nos solutions c'est soit utile c'est ce
que nous avons fait en allant audité au
coeur du réseau social facebook
ce qu'il faisait mais nous n'avons
jamais abandonné nos programmes
prérogatives d'état il y à ce que devra
faire le réseau social ce qui est dans
la proposition de loi de la députée
laetitia via qui est de mettre à niveau
son système de régulation interne mais
l'état n'abandonne aucune de ses
prérogatives
nous devons en appeler à la
responsabilité individuelle il n'est pas
possible aujourd'hui que l'on puisse
impunément insulté injurié sur internet
sans que la justice aille vous cherchez
derrière c'est la première chose
cela nécessite de poser des règles
claires et l'état le fera
c'est ce que nous avons fait en
défendant les idées aux français et
européens c'est ce que nous faisons
d'ailleurs au niveau européen puisque
nous l'avons fait sur la directive
droits d'auteur que vous défendez nous
continuerons madame la députée a mené ce
combat là mais c'est la triste
nous continuerons madame la présidente a
mené ce combat un moment d'inattention
en gardant en tête toutes les
prérogatives de l'état j dante sénatrice
vous avez la parole
vous ne m'avez absolument pas convaincu
vous êtes dans le statut cour
industrielle alors que les meilleurs
experts du numérique
les ingénieurs de la silicon valley sont
en train de nous alerter j'en veux pour
preuve la célèbre casaque wired ou
encore le l'influent site d'actualité
économique business insider
en tout état de cause fallait-il
absolument dérouler le tapis rouge à
mark zuckerberg qui sait je le rappelle
parjurer devant le congrès américain
c'est le new york times qui l'a révélé
et que suite au rapport de mon homologue
damian collins le prêt à le mans
britannique n'hésite pas à qualifier de
gangsters nous ne le vendrons la merci
voilà mme la présidente
la parole est à notre collègue julien
bargeton pour le groupe de la république
en marche
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur jean baptiste lemoyne en
autriche
le vice chancelier a dû démissionner à
la suite d'une collusion avec un état
étranger qui tentent régulièrement de
déstabiliser nos démocraties notamment
via internet et ce n'est pas sans lien
avec la question précédente
il n'est pas seulement reproché au
vice-chancelier autrichien de s'être
aventuré à des promesses mais de mettre
en péril la confidentialité des
informations dont ses services ont pu
avoir connaissance
d'ores et déjà l'autriche est écarté de
certaines réunions et de certaines
informations qui sont communiquées
notamment par le gouvernement allemand
cette affaire est donc profonde elle est
grave elle touche à la souveraineté et à
l'indépendance de l'europe
les nationalistes se font les ennemis de
l'intérêt national qu'ils liquident au
profit de leurs intérêts personnels et
au profit de puissances étrangères
ma question est double à court terme
quelle est la position de notre pays
face à la crise de la coalition
autrichienne et notamment sur le
fonctionnement des institutions en
particulier le conseil de l'europe
par ailleurs l'influencent d'état
étranger dans le déroulement régulier
d'élections et plus largement dans la
vie politique pose question
le parlement sera t'il informés
d'éventuelles attaques de potentielles
attaques ayant pour cible le bon
déroulement des élections européennes
comme d'autres élections à venir je vous
remercie quand vous répondre à la parole
et au secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de rop vous affaires étrangères
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur julien bargeton les
citoyens
européens sont libres et souverains et
entendent bien rester
les états européens sont libres et
souverains et entendent bien le rester
ça paraît une évidence ici dans cet
hémicycle
mais les événements de ce week-end
effectivement sont préoccupants
préoccupant parce qu'on voit les
ingérences se dessiner et pour notre
part la france le gouvernement français
agissant soit titre national soit au
niveau des instances européennes a
souhaité se prémunir et protéger cette
démocratie européenne que nous
chérissons un certain nombre de mesures
ont été prises dispositions législatives
visant à prohiber le financement par des
établissements bancaires
en dehors de l'union européenne mise en
place d'un réseau d' alerte européen
pour s'informer des attaques détectées
il est temps également d'aller plus loin
au niveau européen le président la
république a souhaité la mise en place
d'une véritable agence de protection de
la démocratie européenne pour bien viser
à pallier toutes les attaques qu'elle
soit cyber qu'elle soit de toute nature
et il est vrai que nous le devons nous
le devons à ces hommes des femmes qui il
y a trente ans je pense à lech walesa je
pense à vaclav havel je pense à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui avec une petite
bougie sont venus au bout de
totalitarisme qui ont fait tomber ce mur
de 165 km avec un mirador tous les 100
mètres et qui ont permis la
réunification du continent européen
des peuples européens alors n'en
déplaise à marine le pen
une europe européenne ne fait pas de
génuflexions à monsieur ban donne une
europe européenne ne se compromet pas
comme ses alliés autrichien au parlement
européen une europe européenne elle est
unie elle est démocratique et libre
merci
tu marches de temps merci monsieur le
ministre cette affaire illustre l'écart
entre la vigueur des discours et le
froid cynisme des actes au delà c'est
une question sécurité qui est posée ne
soyons pas naïfs ne baissons pas la
garde
ni pour nos nations unies pour l'europe
merci beaucoup merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
nathalie delattre pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
jusqu'à quand la france sera t-elle
eynden de tuberculose bovine avec 115
cas environ par an notre pays était
considéré jusque là comme relativement
stable mais le nombre de cas augmente la
nouvelle aquitaine est la région de
france à plus de touchés par ce
phénomène
après la charente et la dordogne le
département de la gironde découvre
quelques cas fabienne et maire de son
village mais elle est aussi éleveuse
dans le libournais
elle est à la tête d'une petite
exploitation et elle vit dans l'angoissé
elle a dû faire face à l'abattage d'une
vache une vache me direz vous ce n'est
rien mais pour fabienne c'est tout
d'autant que sa vache a été sacrifié
pour rien parce qu'en fait elle n'était
pas qui barrent curieuse elle était une
force positive
et oui la technique de nos tests date
d'une cinquantaine d'années et elle
n'est pas totalement fiable
monsieur le ministre il nous faut
investir très vite la question de
l'actualisation des moyens de dépistage
de la tuberculose bovine et de leur
fiabilité
d'autant que le gibier porteurs de la
maladie et pas forcément celui auquel
nous pourrions penser de prime abord car
familier et non classés nuisibles comme
le blaireau lanxess recommande
d'ailleurs d'effectuer des prélèvements
sur un échantillonnage représentatif de
cet animal autour des zones d'abattage
nous attendons avec impatience monsieur
le ministre les décisions sur le terrain
en la matière j'en profite pour
féliciter la fédération de chasse de la
gironde
la ddsp et les élus locaux qui ont réagi
délais
mier cas en mettant en place des
systèmes de collecte des déchets de la
venaison pour limiter le phénomène
monsieur le ministre alors que la
filière est confrontée à une baisse de
12% de la consommation de viande sur ces
dix dernières années et qu'elle doit
faire face aux dérives sans précédent de
l'intelligence animalistes quels moyens
elle et vous affectez sur la recherche
et sur l'assouplissement de la
réglementation pour endiguer la
tuberculose bovine
l'enjeu est économique fondée sanitaire
culturel au civil et surtout humains
pour fabienne et pour tous ses collègues
pour nos éleveurs français merci
la parole est maintenant pouvons
répondre au ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation monsieur didier
guillaume merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices madame la sénatrice
je veux réaffirmer
devant le sénat cet après midi que la
france est toujours indemne de
tuberculose bovine
elle l'est depuis 2001 il n'y a aucune
raison qu'elle ne le reste pas en tout
cas tous les services travaillent entre
eux les services privés des services
publics la fédération de chasse vous
venez de le souligner et ce travail et
ce travail et effet mais toutefois le
nombre de foyers augmentée vous l'avez
dit vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est
pourquoi afin de renforcer le pilotage
et la lutte contre la tuberculose bovine
un plan national été mis en place en
2010 est ce que nous avions vu qu'il y
avait cette difficulté est mon
prédécesseur avait lancé ce plan
national ce plan continue à se déployer
avec l'ensemble des acteurs vous les
avez cités au niveau national et local
en 2010 823 foyer ses 123 de trop les
123 foyers ont été mis en évidence sur
le territoire national soit une
augmentation de près de 30% sur l'année
précédente et 80% de ces foyers sont
sans nouvelles aquitaine c'est pour ça
que vous posez la question je suppose
dont six foyers ont été détectés dans
votre département delà de la gironde en
2018 et 2019
cette augmentation résulte notamment il
faut le dire par la meilleure
surveillance des zones et une
amélioration de la qualité dépistage
vous l'avez dit vous le savez on nous en
avons parlé et aujourd'hui les tests qui
sont faits permettent d'être d'avoir des
retours plus fins et d'avoir des
dépistages plus plus nombreux mais
fabienne votre annie qui a eu une vache
abattue n'en a que faire que les tests
soient à plus précis ce qu'elle veut
savoir c'est réellement quand est-ce que
cela va va s'arrêter les tests sont
beaucoup plus performants et vous le
disais vous le disiez des résultats faux
positifs et c'est je pense le cadre de
votre de votre ami et éleveuse et je
sais combien pour les éleveurs c'est
important aussi la mise en évidence ces
nouveaux foyers nous concerne nous avait
évoqué concernant les gibiers notamment
les blaireaux le ministère et les
services du ministère font tout pour
faire en sorte que la france reste un
des mots pour surveiller de plus près
possible cela et le ministère
à mobiliser 20 millions d'euros dédiés
d'ores et déjà à l'indemnisation de ces
foyers jour merci merci monsieur le
ministre parole et à jacques grosperrin
pour le groupe l'est républicain
non chers collègues je suis très à mon
tour interpellé madame la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
madame la ministre donc en fin de
semaine dernière près de cinquante mille
lycéens ont fait le feraient les frais
d'un bug de parcours sup la mise en
place de ce nouveau dispositif
nombreuses étaient les personnes à
s'émouvoir de l'impact psychologique des
situations liées à la temps de réponse
et de vérification des classements mais
qui aurait pu prévoir un tel ascenseur
émotionnel pour ces jeunes gens un mois
du début des épreuves du baccalauréat
comment en est on arrivé là moins de
deux ans après le fiasco d'apb les
témoignages de lycéens issus des
familles inquiètes et affluent et en
filigrane se dessine à nouveau la grande
interrogation de ceux ci à propos des
algorithmes et du manque de transparence
de la plateforme vous nous expliquer que
400 formations auraient fait des erreurs
humaines mais comment autant de
formations montait lui aussi ainsi faire
tant d'erreurs
n'y at il pas eu vraiment aucune
instruction de vos services ou à tout le
moins les directives données nous tel
pas pêché par manque de clarté dans les
deux cas madame la ministre il a mené de
votre responsabilité
nous sommes nombreux à nous interroger à
nous demander si les formations non
patissia m'encourager à gonfler
excessivement leur taux de
surréservations pour raccourcir les
délais d'attentes pour les candidats et
accélérer la fameuse convergence
madame la ministre au sujet grave la
représentation nationale vous va vous
écoutez pour entendre en sorte que les
908 candidats ce qui sut parcours sur
leurs familles attendent des réponses
claires et précises jouer
madame la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et
l'innovation de la vidal vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jacques grosperrin
vous avez raison de lui rappeler les
erreurs qui ont été commises par les
formations sont inacceptables et elles
ont suscité beaucoup de faux espoirs
chez de nombreux candidats mais au-delà
de ça sur les 2 % de formation qui ont
commis ces erreurs
ce que je dois dire c'est que à la fois
le service central qui gère parcours
super qui a vu apparaître ces erreurs
comme les responsables de ces formations
ont souhaité réagir immédiatement de
façon à ce que l'ensemble des neuf cent
mille candidats puissent avec quelques
heures de retard et bien obtenir des
propositions dans un contexte qui avait
été totalement corrigé pendant la nuit
et c'est l'accompagnement humain qui a
aussi été mis en place par les rectorats
par les responsables de ces formations
par les professeurs principaux et les
proviseurs des lycées qui accueillent
ces lycéens que je voudrais saluer
aujourd'hui ce à quoi vous faites
référence et c'est ce que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'expliquer tout à l'heure
n'a rien à voir avec ce phénomène
d'erreurs qui s'est produit il est
normal que lorsqu'une formation à 30
places elle puisse appeler une
quarantaine de candidats car nous le
savons tous tous ces candidats ne se
présenteront pas à la rentrée et c'est
d'ailleurs un nombre de places qui du
coup ne peuvent pas être offerts à
l'ensemble des candidats
ça c'est ce que l'on appelle
effectivement un taux d'appel supérieure
de 30% à la norme mais les erreurs que
nous avons constatée et que le service
d'un coup reçu peut on constater était
une toute autre ampleur
ce sont des bts à 12 places qui ont
appelé plus de 300 candidats ce sont des
classes préparatoires à 30 places qui
ont appelé plus de 600 candidats
ils ont simplement interverti le chiffre
en d'appel avec le chiffre de la liste
d'attentes et c'est ce sujet là que j'ai
demandé à l'inspection générale de
vérifier de façon à ce que nous
puissions mettre en place des contrôles
qui évite que ces erreurs humaines se
reproduise jour merci monsieur
grosperrin
cinquante mille candidats affectés par
le bug sur les quelques 900 mille
inscrits c'est trop 400 formations qui
se sont trompés alors que l'année
précédente aucune s'est trompé donc ça
nous interpelle est ce que cette année
c'était pas c'est clair ou mal
accompagné si erreur j'entends bien
votre empathie aujourd'hui vous excuse
mais je crois que ça aurait été
important aussi que les lycéens les
oiseaux en aussi et puis vous êtes
appelé madame la ministre sur le fait
que les boursiers actuellement ou une
réponse positive alors qu'il ya des
étudiants des lycéens très brillant qui
nous occupe un résultat et ça les
interrogeant tout casser les
interpellent au sein de la même classe
et à l'heure où justement nous venons de
voter avec le ministre jean michel
bancaire l'école de la confiance il nous
faut retrouver cette transparence de ce
parcours supiot merci merci la parole
est que notre collègue noël ressort pour
le groupe de la république en marche la
parole leur collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre vous avez annoncé
plusieurs mesures concernant le tourisme
et notamment un assouplissement des
mesures de des taxes pour les touristes
étrangers hors union européenne
nous ne pouvons que saluer cette
initiative qui devrait soutenir notre
balance des paiements et la consommation
en effet la france demeure la première
destination touristique au monde en
nombre de touristes mais pas en terme de
recette où nous sommes derrière
l'espagne
un concurrent direct tout l'enjeu est
ici de rétrécir l' avantage
concurrentiel de nos voisins sur les
conditions de détaxe aussi
l'optimisation de la mécanique de la
détaxe va permettre une augmentation des
sommes dépensées par les touristes en
2010 8 56 2 milliards d'euros ont été
dépensés en france par les touristes
étrangers
monsieur le ministre quels sont les
objectifs pour les prochaines années en
termes de dépenses des touristes
étrangers en france
par ailleurs plus de cent mille emplois
ne sont pas pourvus dans le secteur
touristique et notamment dans
l'hôtellerie restauration
vous avez annoncé plusieurs mesures
telles que
la création d'un comité de filière pour
le touriste la mise en place d'une
plateforme numérique ou la mise en place
d'un contrat liant une douzaine de
branches liées au secteur du tourisme
pouvez vous nous préciser le calendrier
de ces mesures et les objectifs du
gouvernement en termes d'emploi aussi
comme vous l'avez précisé à plusieurs
reprises les problèmes de recrutement du
secteur touristique sont essentiellement
liés due aux conditions de travail et de
rénumération de l'offre d'emploi des
avancées significatives sont elles
attendues concernant l'attractivité de
ces emplois je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est au secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'europe
affaires étrangères monsieur jean
baptiste que moi devait la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
madame noël ressent effectivement le
sujet du tourisme vous vous y êtes
employé pour faire rayonner le
territoire du vésulien de l'yonne et ça
participe naturellement de
l'attractivité de la france alors le
comité interministériel du tourisme
réunis sous l'autorité du premier
ministre
vendredi dernier a pris effectivement un
certain nombre de mesures afin
d'atteindre et bien des objectifs
ambitieux l'objectif de 100 millions de
touristes internationaux à l'échéance de
2020 et vous avez insisté également sur
l'objectif de recettes générées par ces
touristes internationaux 60 milliards
d'euros attendus en 2020
pour cela des mesures très concrètes ont
été prises visant à favoriser
effectivement et bien l'achat il faut
avoir en tête que les touristes
dépensent seulement 20% de leur budget
en achats en france contrairement à des
chiffres comme 40% à londres et donc
d'où ces mesures visant à étendre la
durée sur laquelle la détaxe que ce
faire d'où des mesures également visant
à augmenter le plafond en numéraire qui
est rendu à ces touristes parce que ils
le dépensent à nouveau ce numéraire
avant de quitter le sol national
le
cette ambition touristique elle se
décline également en matière de
ressources humaines
effectivement on ne peut pas se résoudre
à voir cent mille emplois non pourvus
dans ce secteur de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration les professionnels du
tourisme se sont emparés du sujet avec
force avec la mission également conduite
par la députée frédérique lardet et eh
bien ils vont employer les outils mis à
disposition par la loi pacte comme
l'intéressement la participation et
l'épargné salariale
effectivement mettre aussi en lien
l'offre et la demande sur une plateforme
numérique c'est très important
donc nous avons là aussi une dernière
piste avec la mise en valeur de notre
patrimoine
une le lancement d'une chaîne de parador
avec eux la banque des territoires parce
que c'est avec les territoires en
partenariat que nous allons aller aux
résultats pour créer des richesses pour
l'ensemble de nos départements et de nos
communes
merci la parole notre collègue françois
bonhomme pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole la
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre l'intérieur monsieur ministre
mars dernier le rappeur nick conrad été
condamné pour provocation au crime pour
son clip intitulé pendez les blancs
manifestement ni la honte d'une
condamnation pénale ni la peine
prononcée ne leur ont amené à réfléchir
en effet le rappeur hommelibre comme il
aime à se présenter lui-même viennent de
réitérer son propos dans son nouveau
clip aux paroles sans ambiguïté je cite
je baise la france je brûle la france
jusqu'à l'agonie
tel est le refrain lancinant de ce qu'il
présente comme une oeuvre de l'esprit
en dehors des propos tenus les images
laisse également peu de place à
l'interprétation
dans ce clip à large diffusion on y voit
l'auteur après sa démobilisation berline
clamer sa haine de la france et procéder
avec méthode à la strangulation d'une
jeune femme à terre tout cela suivi d'un
oral dans ralenti comme plaisant filmant
son rictus de satisfaction devant son
crime
amené à s'expliquer sur ses propos et
ses images où l'auteur évoque tour à
tour la faute des médias et de la
mentalité française qui selon lui
refuserait je cite d'ouvrir le sujet
épineux de lentilles esclavagisme de la
france or monsieur le ministre ne
saurait en pareil cas s'abriter
derrière la liberté de création ou la
liberté d'expression pour te justifier
les limites aux me semble-t-il largement
été outrepassées vous avez indiqué
monsieur ministre procédait à un
signalement sur la patente pharos et
saisir le procureur de la république
c'est bien nous y souscrivons mais on ne
peut pas se contenter de se défausser
sur la justice nous attendons une
réponse politique ferme et une
affirmation claire de nos principes dès
lors monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous au delà de la condamnation
de principe obligé faire en sorte que ce
type de propos n'est plus droit de cité
d'entre eux pays mais sur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bonhomme eux vous
rappeler le contenu donc de ce vidéo
clip de ce rappeur ni que conrad qui une
nouvelle fois tient des propos
particulièrement injurieux haineux mais
qui s'en prennent directement à la
france jeudi une nouvelle fois parce que
vous avez raison de le rappeler dans un
précédent clip il avait appelé à prendre
des blancs et donc je voulais vous dire
d'abord que le gouvernement partage bien
évidemment votre émotion et votre
indignation devant ces propos injurieux
qui sont inacceptables et qui
effectivement ne doivent pas être
acceptées ni conrad doit comprendre que
de tels propos ne peuvent pas s'abriter
et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
sénateur derrière la liberté
d'expression ou derrière une quelconque
liberté artistique l'insultent et la
haine ne sont pas de l'art insultes et
la haine ne vont pas dans le sens du
vivre ensemble auquel nous appelons tous
dans notre démocratie française mais
surtout l'insulté la haine tombent sous
le coup de la loi pénale
et c'est en ce sens que christophe
castaner dès dimanche à dans le cadre
d'un article 40 du code de procédure
pénale saisi le procureur de la
république de paris qui a immédiatement
ouvert une enquête préliminaire dont il
a saisi la brigade de répression de la
délinquance contre les personnes de la
police judiciaire de la préfecture de
police de paris qui a ouvert au titre de
l'apologie de crime d'atteinte
volontaire aggravé qui est une
infraction extrêmement grave et les
enquêteurs donc sont à l'oeuvre et
des auditions ont lieu très
prochainement mais là je ne peux en dire
plus bien évidemment ça se passe sous
l'autorité du parquet dans le même temps
christophe castaner a souhaité que nous
puissions saisir la plateforme pharos
qui travaillent à obtenir le retrait de
ce contenu qui est manifestement
illicite
dans le même temps donc pharos travail à
cette possibilité de retrait mais ce que
je veux dire aussi c'est que cette cette
affaire doit aussi nous faire persévérer
poursuivre dans la voie qu'ils aient les
nôtres la nôtre d'adopter un texte de
loi c'est la proposition de loi qui sera
bientôt présenté à l'assemblée et ce
projet qu'il faut aussi que nous
portions au parlement européen auprès
des institutions européennes pour
obtenir comme c'est le cas pour le
compte les contenus terroristes le
retrait dans les plus brefs délais des
contenus haineux comme c'est le cas
malheureusement avec une nouvelle fois
ce clip de nick conrad merci monsieur
madame ou monsieur ministre j'observe
toutefois quand même que la diffusion du
clip
malgré les signalements sur pharos
demeure et d'autre part j'aurais voulu
une condamnation en général parce que
j'ai observé le silence gêné et
assourdissantes de madame schiappa qui
est en charge de l'égalité hommes-femmes
et des discriminations
pourtant toujours prompte à fanfaronner
et apte à théâtraliser ses sorties
toujours prompt à manier quick leur et
notamment le hashtag notamment le
hashtag ne rien laisser passer et serait
donnée surtout beaucoup plus de force à
vos propos
[Applaudissements]
tu as parlé à notre collègue gisèle
jourda pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain vous avez la parole merci
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances j'y associe
macaulay de sophie calle paulhan
monsieur le ministre fin novembre 2018
vous vous étiez engagé à ce que le prix
réglementés de l'électricité n'augmente
pas pendant l'hiver vous reportez alors
l'application des recommandations de la
commission de régulation de l'énergie à
savoir l'augmentation des tarifs en juin
prochain vous allez valider les nouveaux
tarifs avec une augmentation
considérable de 5,9 pour cent majoré de
1 % supplémentaires en août soit une
augmentation de 85 euros par an pour un
ménage se chauffant à l'électricité et
la récente augmentation du chèque
énergie d'un montant de 50 euros ne
permettra pas de la compenser ces
hausses de tarifs sont très largement
contestée directement par le médiateur
national de l'énergie et par les
associations de défense des
consommateurs qui alerte sur la baisse
du pouvoir d'achat que cela va entraîner
indirectement par l'autorité de la
concurrence qui s'est élevé contre les
changements de méthode et d'analysé de
marché adoptées par la commission de
régulation de l'énergie qui conduisent à
cette forte hausse des tarifs ces
augmentations sont le fruit d'un
mécanisme même posé pour favoriser la
concurrence au détriment bien sûr des
consommateurs or la précarité
énergétique est une triste réalité tout
103 millions 300 mille ménages en france
soit 6 millions 700 mille personnes qui
restreignent leur utilisation de
chauffage ont froid dans leur logement
vivent dans une seule pièce l'hiver et
s'endettent pour payer leurs factures
en réponse à la crise dès gilet jaune
vous promettiez un gain de pouvoir
d'achat aux ménages français ma question
est simple allez vous vraiment appliquer
la hausse préconisée en pleine
conscience des répercussions sur le
pouvoir d'achat des français
par ailleurs vous avez parlé de modifier
le mode de calcul des tarifs de
l'électricité sans rien préciser de vos
intentions
pouvez vous nous en dire plus pour
répondre la parole est commise de
l'économie et des finances monsieur
bruno le maire vous avez la parole
le monsieur le président madame moeurs
la sénatrice la proposition de tarif qui
était appliqué retenu par le ministre
d'état c'est une proposition qui est
issue d'une décision de la commission de
régulation de l'énergie d'une faisons
que je suive les recommandations de la
commission de régulation de l'énergie
il n'empêche que la france garde
aujourd'hui je le rappelle l'un des
tarifs les plus bas de l'électricité
pour lés particuliers grâce à notre mix
énergétique
vous nous parler aussi du pouvoir
d'achat à la suite de la crise des gilet
jaune le pouvoir d'achat c'est le
travail et la philosophie de ce
gouvernement
la philosophie de cette majorité c'est
que c'est par le travail et par l'emploi
que nous redonnerons du pouvoir d'achat
aux français et vous devriez vous
réjouir que pour la première fois depuis
dix ans nous avons un niveau de chômage
qui enfin commence à baisser et que nous
avons le taux d'emploi le plus élevé en
france depuis dix ans vous devriez vous
réjouir de ce que nous avons pris
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
toutes les décisions nécessaires pour
que le travail paye
en france nous avons supprimé la
cotisation assurance maladie assurance
chômage
nous avons augmenté la prime d'activité
nous avons supprimé la taxe à 20 % sur
l'intéressement pour développer
l'intéressement et faire en sorte que
tous ceux qui travaillent puissent être
associés aux résultats des entreprises
le président de la république vient
d'annoncer également une baisse de 5
milliards d'euros de l'impôt sur le
revenu pour tous ceux qui travaillent
vous le voyez au delà de la question de
l'énergie la question clé pour nos
compatriotes tous ceux qui vont
travailler tous ceux qui en emploient
tous ceux qui sont salariés
c'est pouvoir vivre dignement de leur
travail
et bien c'est l'honneur de cette
majorité de faire en sorte que tous ceux
qui travaillent puissent vivre dignement
de leur emploi
c'est notre philosophie c'est notre
politique
ce sont nos résultats merci la parole
est à leurs collègues sonia de la
prévôté pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
vous avez la parole de la provôté merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
solidarités de la santé madame la
ministre alors que le sénat s'apprête à
discuter du projet de loi santé
je souhaite interroger sur les pratiques
du site d'octo libé des plateformes en
ligne de rendez vous médicaux
cette situation amène quatre sujets
dangereux pour notre vision régaliennes
et protectrice de la chanter primo la
plateforme permet la prise de rendez
vous rapide de consultation à toute
heure du jour et elle et cela plaît mais
est-ce souhaitable une réponse immédiate
à un besoin de santé oublie la
prévention la prise en compte des
habitudes de vie l'histoire du patient
l'éducation thérapeutique
deuxio elle contractualise pour cela
avec des cabinets des médecins
si le médecin traitant de la personne et
non contractuelle avec dr ibles site ali
que ce rendez vous est impossible
mais qu'à cela ne tienne il faut pose
une liste d'autres médecins proximité
adhérent e et disponible
ceci est totalement contradictoire avec
les notions de médecins référents et de
parcours de soins cartiaux la plateforme
contractualise avec des cliniques
établissements de santé hôpitaux publics
dont les établissements de l'ap-hp
quand un patient seront sur le site de
l'ap-hp par exemple pour prendre rendez
vous il doit créer un compte dr il a si
les patients de l'ap-hp doivent
s'inscrire sur un site privé alors que
l'hôpital public faut-il le rappeler est
financé par l'argent public
il ya là me semble il me semble un
problème éthique grave
enfin cette alliance entre cliniques
hôpitaux professionnels de santé et
d'octo libre créé un risque majeur pour
la protection des données de santé
en effet la plateforme collecte des
données personnelles des patients le nom
de leur médecin le motif de consultation
des examens complémentaires mais aussi
les comptes rendus de téléconsultation
en france ces données sont très encadrés
par le r j mais si un jour la
start-up devenu licorne venait à passer
sous le giron américain par exemple il y
aurait conflit avec le cloud ac beaucoup
plus laxiste
madame la ministre il y a urgence avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard quelles mesures
comptez vous prendre pour sécuriser les
passions et les pratiques médicales
face à cette évolution et au risque
d'ubs et risation de la santé je vous
remercie
et pour la parole est à mme la ministre
des solidarités de santé de la manière
du visage avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs dessinateur madame la
sénatrice sonia de la provôté bien sûr
j'entends votre inquiétude sur
l'utilisation des données de santé
vous prenez l'exemple de la plate forme
de rendez vous en ligne en france vous
savez les données de santé sont très
intègre encadré grains ce règlement
général européen de la protection des
données le rgp des les données de santé
sont encore davantage encadré puisque
chaque société qui on récolte est chargé
de les chiffrer et de les stocker chez
un hébergeur à gré des données
personnelles de santé des utilisateurs
sont ainsi validées par des prestataires
ayant reçu un agrément certifié
hébergeur de données de santé et leur
exploitation est très surveillé les
plateformes auquel vous faites référence
respecte l'ensemble des dispositions
législatives et réglementaires
françaises et européennes relatives à la
protection des données personnelles
madame la sénatrice je suis également
très attaché à la protection des données
et je voudrais prendre pour exemple ce
que nous avons fait dans le projet doit
de santé que vous serez amené à examiner
dans une semaine
l'article 11 du projet de loi qui est
dédié aux elfes data up propose
justement un équilibre entre les usages
innovants et efficaces des données de
santé en vue d'améliorer nos
connaissances et la promo d'une
protection de la vie privée
cet équilibre a d'ailleurs été saluée
par le conseil d'état qui a considéré
que le projet de loi ne méconnaît aucune
exigence de valeur constitutionnelle ou
conventionnelle dès lors que le système
national des données de santé apporte
des garanties suffisantes pour
l'utilisation des données auxquelles il
donne l'accès vous aurez tout le loisir
de le vérifier lors des discussions
parlementaires
nous serons extrêmement vigilants à ce
que aucun français ne soit inquiété
quant à l'utilisation faite sur ses
données de santé
c'est ce que nous devons à nos
concitoyens je vous remercie il valable
de la provôté
oui madame la mise j'entends bien le à
l'heure du dossier médical partagé on
répète aux patients qui sont
propriétaires de leur donner il faut
qu'on soit très attentifs à ce sujet ce
sont des richesses extrêmement convoité
et il faut aussi espérer que ces
plateformes et que c'est son entreprise
innovante reste française ou européenne
parce que si elle passe dans des pays
qui sont bien moins bien plus laxiste
que nous eh bien là les données de santé
je ne donne pas cher de leur avenir
merci mesdames et messieurs les
ministres nous en avons terminé avec les
questions au gouvernement d'un prochaine
question d'actualité auront lieu le
mardi 28 mai à 16h45
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 17h45
donc en fait en cinq minutes pour le
projet de loi portant création d'une
taxe sur les services numériques et
modification de la trajectoire de baisse
de l'impôt sur les sociétés d'un séance
est suspendue pour cinq minutes de
bonheur voilà
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement où les
sénateurs ont évoqué notamment la sphère
vincent lambert et la reprise des
traitements de vincent lambert ordonnée
par la cour d'appel de paris alors que
ses soins avait été arrêtée depuis hier
matin le sénateur les républicains
bernard fournier s'est positionné plutôt
en faveur de la reprise des soins de
vincent lambert et il a évoqué lui
minutes l'humilité dont il fallait faire
preuve face à cette situation
douloureuse et il a demandé la fin des
certitudes tout fait sur la fin de vie
en france la ministre des solidarités de
la santé agnès buzyn lui a répondu en
confirmant la reprise des soins de
vincent lambert mais en rappelant que
tous les arrêts de traitement décidé
aujourd'hui en france se faisait en
conformité avec la loi de 2016 contre
l'obstination déraisonnable et puis
agnès buzyn à encourager chaque français
à écrire ses directives anticipées pour
faciliter la décision des proches et des
médecins en cas de fin de vie et puis
deux questions ont été posées sur la
plateforme parcours sur la plateforme
d'orientation vers l'enseignement
supérieur qui a connu un grave
dysfonctionnement puisque des dizaines
de milliers de lycéens la semaine
dernière ont d'abord reçu des réponses
positives d'admission avant d'essuyer
des refus d'une grande déception de ses
dizaines de milliers de lycéens le
sénateur communiste pierre ouzeau
liasses a dénoncé la politique de
surbooking de sur réservation effectuée
par certaines formations et encouragée
par le gouvernement la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur frédéric vidal
lui a répondu en assumant cette
politique de surbooking de
surréservations pour faciliter le
remplissage de ces filières mais elle a
réfuté tout lien avec ce
dysfonctionnement avec le
dysfonctionnement de la semaine dernière
qui est due selon elle à des erreurs
humaines des services académiques qui
ont confondu les listes des candidats
admis avec les listes des candidats en
attente voilà delphine pour les temps
forts de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
merci beaucoup alexandre poussard pour
toutes vos précisions et on va continuer
débrief de cette séance de questions
d'actualité avec catherine morin
desailly
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation d'être la présidente de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
de la communication du sénat sénatrice
centriste de la seine maritime on vous
entendu interpellé le gouvernement sur
la question de la position de la france
face aux géants du numérique et sur la
question de la régulation des réseaux
sociaux on va raconter à la réponse de
cédric haut et geoffrey réagir juste
après l'émergence de ces acteurs
appellent une obligation de résultat aux
démocraties pour une raison simple c'est
que si les seuls états qui savent
efficacement réguler les grands acteurs
de l'internet réseaux sociaux et
plateformes sont les acteurs autoritaire
où les pouvoirs autoritaires
alors nos citoyens se tourneront vers
des solutions autoritaires
encore faut-il madame la sénatrice
madame la présidente que nos citoyens
nos solutions c'est soit utile c'est ce
que nous avons fait en allant audité au
coeur du réseau social facebook
ce qu'ils faisaient mais nous n'avons
jamais abandonné nos programmes
prérogatives d'état il y à ce que devra
faire le réseau social ce qui est dans
la proposition de loi de la députée
laetitia via qui est de mettre à niveau
son système de régulation interne mais
l'état n'abandonne aucune de ses
prérogatives
nous devons en appeler à la
responsabilité individuelle il n'est pas
possible aujourd'hui que l'on puisse
impunément insulté injurié sur internet
sans que la justice aille vous cherchez
derrière c'est la première chose
cela nécessite de poser des règles
claires et l'état le fera
c'est ce que nous avons fait en
défendant les idées aux français et
européens c'est ce que nous faisons
d'ailleurs au niveau européen puisque
nous l'avons fait sur la directive
droits d'auteur que vous défendez
catherine morin desailly vous n'avez pas
une fête est satisfaite par la réponse
du secrétaire d'état en charge du
numérique
c'est complètement deadeye il ya aucune
réponse apportée il dit simplement nous
allons continuer à affirmer nos
prérogatives d'état mais en même temps
que dit le président de la république
qui dit qu'on va co réguler et que les
plateformes sont tout à fait d'accord
pour enlever les contenus haineux bref
c'est tout à fait irréaliste c'est tout
à fait illusoire
j'ai voulu insister en interpellant donc
cedrico sur le fait que de par le monde
les positions sont complètement à
contre-courant de la position française
c'est à dire qu'ici et là les meilleurs
experts du numérique les ingénieurs la
silicon valley affirme que finalement
facebook a failli que le modèle de
plateforme telle qui s'est développé
n'est pas
durable et qu'il faut démanteler voilà
on est dans un oligopole un oligopole
qui tout puissant le système le modèle
économique qui vise à capter toujours
plus de nenê faire toujours plus de
gains et utiliser ces données comme bon
leur semble et vraiment un modèle
n'efface et qu'il faut sans doute
questionner tout cela là on est dans une
forme de complaisance naïve qui et alaa
qui va à l'encontre d'ailleurs ce que
font nos voisins allemands qui depuis
toujours
depuis toujours on était beaucoup plus
lucide beaucoup plus exigeant sur ces
questions quand éclate la sphère snowdon
les allemands réagissant guère à merka
les rallys hollande se contente de
recevoir mark zuckerber même chose on
lui déroule pareil de tapis rouge quand
d'autres affaires éclatent comme cette
fameuse affaire quand brut analytica où
il ya des dérives à verrait donc dérives
politiques des dérives éthiques
démocratique qu'on manipule les opinions
au moment d'un scrutin important et bien
les allemands réagissent ils disent faut
arrêter avec ces agrégateurs de données
c'est plus possible
nous on aime ou on est complaisant on
dit tout va bien circulé bonnes gens on
va peut-être pouvoir qu régulé avec ses
plateformes ce n'est pas possible je
vous le dis pour avoir travaillé
beaucoup sur ces sujets il faut être
ferme et désormais il faut avoir des
règles très strictes qui notamment
permettent la maîtrise totale des
données des internautes
senna va débuter l'examen justement dans
la création de la taxe gaffard ça
pourrait revenir dans la discussion
justement cette question de
l'utilisation des données sur les
plateformes tout à fait parce que c'est
un ensemble la souveraineté numérique
c'est-à-dire la maîtrise de notre propre
destin ce notre propre territoire lequel
vous travaillez voilà c'est pas
d'ailleurs le protectionnisme c'est un
bon temps à être maîtres de notre destin
est bien le comporte plusieurs volets et
à la question fiscale puisque l'évasion
fiscale l'optimisation fiscale dégâts
femme s'appelait moyen de l'action
publique et qui a toute la valeur
ajoutée de ce que nous produisons donc
un vrai sujet de économiques sains et
d'avenir de notre civilisation
il ya des questions de données de
protection des données faut renforcer le
règlement général la protection des
données
on a avancé en europe on l'a votée il ya
eu des questions de politique
industrielle
il faut construire un écosystème et en
crée un écosystème
en europe du numérique peut-être pas un
système souverain mais au moins avoir
des géants du numérique ça suppose
revoir nos règles de concurrence au
niveau europe1 fr tout un travail aussi
pour se doter d'une politique ambitieuse
dans ce domaine et enfin dernier volet
sur lequel j'ai beaucoup travaillé
c'est la montée en compétences
numériques de tous notamment des zi des
politiques d administration et de tout à
chacun pour qu'on puisse savoir dans
quel système on se trouve et maîtriser
les choses là on est complètement livré
dans dans cette espèce d'écosystèmes
dont on ne maîtrise rien du tout il faut
savoir de quoi il s'agit on va continuer
cet entretien catherine morin desailly
vous le savez c'est le principe de cette
émission va continuer les réactions avec
le thème tran huy salle des conférences
aux côtés du sénateur et l'ère jacques
grosperrin et l'interpellé à la ministre
frédéric vidal sur les couacs parcours
sup effectivement vous avez tout à
l'heure un questionné la ministre sur le
dysfonctionnement qui ont eu lieu sur
parcours sud déjà ce que vous avez jugé
sa réponse satisfaisante satisfaisant de
riz véritablement pas si je crois
qu'elle est en situation difficile
vis-à-vis ça on peut pas accepter alors
que j'ai entendu 50000 67000 je crois
qu'elle même ne sais pas le nombre de
lycéens qui ont été affectés par par
cela mais en tout cas on peut
s'interroger sur le fait que sur 400
formations qui eut autant d'erreurs
alors que l'année dernière la limite
paquet il n'y avait pas d'erreur je
pense que il ya eu vraiment des
difficultés par rapport à ça comment
expliquer pour vous ces erreurs à ce
qu'il y à une pression du ministère sur
les universités pour accélérer la
procédure aller plus vite que l'an
dernier alors que par conçu par été très
critiqués on se rappelle bien sûr bien
sûr je crois qu'ils ont voulu donner de
la fluidité en voulant donner de la
fluidité
ils ont fait ce qu'on appelle du sud
surbooking c'est là qu'ils ont proposé
plus de place qu'il n'y avait alors
c'est quelque chose qui se fait
habituellement mais il pas dans ces
proportions là une pratique assumer mais
qui a peut-être donné lieu à des dérives
mais complètement je crois qu'il ya eu
un surbooking trop important et il ya eu
une embolie ce du système quoi donc je
crois qu'on peut simplement le regretter
il faut véritablement renouveler la
confiance justement au niveau de ses
enfants de haut niveau de ses élèves
parce qu'ils soient en doute un mois du
baccalauréat
il faut vraiment réfléchir et puis
apporter de la transparence dans tous
ses algorithmes moi je me rends compte
que dans à besançon dans dans ma ville
il y à des lycéennes qui sont en
terminale à ce jour qui sont très
brillante qui sont pas prises par
parcours support médecine alors que la
même classe des élèves lycéenne moins
brillantes sont déjà prises
parce qu'elles sont boursière donc il ya
vraiment d'inspiration pour vous
expliquer des choses parce que entre eux
ils se parlent et ils comprennent pas où
est la faute pour vous est ce qu'il ya
une responsabilité partagée entre le
ministère les missiles et les
universités le rectorat pour pour vous
où se situe le problème le plus moi j'ai
le sentiment qu'il ya une hyène
il ya eu une malfaçon en quelque sorte
une bonne volonté si elle volonté de la
porte et la fluidité est ce qui a fait
que le ministère a voulu mettre de la
pression au niveau des universités mais
je crois qu'il ya eu un
dysfonctionnement ministériel il faudra
quand même que la ministre s'en explique
il ya eu un dysfonctionnement
ministériel dit vous est-ce qu'il ya
aussi eu un dysfonctionnement au niveau
de la communication de la ministre
tout à l'heure vous avez dit qu'elle
avait manqué d'en pâtir elle a manqué
d'empathie en réalité elle a parlé d'
empathie et là une petit un petit souci
d' empathie parce que les les jeunes qui
ont vécu cette c'était difficile
acceptation puis refus non parce qu'une
mode excuses par quiconque
tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle au sénat
où la montée du elle a eu un petit peu
d'empathie vis-à-vis des des jeunes et
c'est la première fois que je l'entends
je pense qu'elle a eu une communication
qui a été gâchée je pense que sa commune
voilà elle aurait dû rétablir les choses
très rapidement dès dimanche parce qu'on
a entendu beaucoup de choses sur le
nombre nombre d'élèves qui ont été
affectés ou pas je pense qu'il faut
véritablement qu'elle soit clair
qu'elles soient transparentes
et puis quelle soit
vivante qu'elle explique aux gens et à
chacun ce qui s'est passé et peut
comprendre qu'il y ait eu une erreur à
elle le faire peut-être son mea culpa
bien merci beaucoup jacques grosperrin
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci à vous merci à vous tous pour
cette réaction catherine morin desailly
on voit ces dysfonctionnements autour de
la plateforme parcours super ça pose
toujours la question du monde de
transparence finalement et notamment
dans les algorithmes pas du tout faut
songer parcours succès 14500 formation
là il ya eu un dysfonctionnement
un bug on va dire sur 397 formation qui
est concerné des déformations sélective
très sélective type bts et ce qui a été
constaté en fait c'est un surnombre de
places mis à disposition va dire les
choses si oui où une surévaluation du
nombre de places est très vite dès le
lendemain d'ailleurs à la fois là
l'équipe park au sud qui quotidiennement
vérifie la la plateforme mais également
les équipes du ministère et les
formations concernées se sont rendu
compte et formation connaît sont rendus
compte qu'ils avaient trop de place et
que ça correspondait pas à la halle à à
la réalité doc a eu une réaction
immédiat le vrai le vrai sujet c'est que
là dedans il ya des jeunes voilà qu'on
désespoir des rêves qui ont une fausse
joie on va dire il faut leur parler bien
entendu il faut bien expliquer ce qu'est
le parcours sup et ce qui est aussi une
filière sélective ont quand même bien
dire que dans des bts ares
fonctionnement informatique mineure
selon vous vous ne dites pas mineurs
qu'on va partir du moment où ça concerne
des jeunes et leur avenir
mais ce que je voulais c'est peut-être
relativiser un petit peu des choses et
rappelé qu'ils étaient peu avant
l'entrée à l'université et dans les
filières super c'était du tirage au sort
ni plus ni moi voilà parce que il n'y
avait pas assez de place pour tout le
monde en gros là il ya quand même eu
depuis la réforme il faut bien le dire
un soin apporté qu'on le veuille ou non
ah voilà
les orientait l'orientation à soit
apportée peut-être aux désirs des jeunes
avec des voeux formulés bon qui est
dysfonctionnements à n + 2 c'est
regrettable mais j'allais dire que c'est
un système encore une fois qui concerne
14500 l'information donc l'erreur est
humaine
elle est regrettable il est important
que le ministère prenne en main cette
problématique et fasse toute la
transparence sur ce qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs au sénat nous demanderons une
explication claire transparence gros sur
ce qui s'est passé
voilà et d'ailleurs nous hissions très
régulièrement frédéric vidal sur la mise
en place de parcours ce sera notre rôle
de suivre cela son rôle est de rassurer
les familles
catherine morin desailly de questions
sur le clip de nick conrad de cet après
midi au sénat je vous propose d'ailleurs
d'écouter les chants montre le président
que de mal sûrs et est justement la
réponse de ministres geoffrey agir juste
après monsieur le ministre il ya
quelques mois un rappeur en mal de
notoriété a commis un clip intitulé
pendez les blancs quelques phrases ce
chef-d'oeuvre je rentre dans des crèches
je tue des bébés blanc attrapé l'éviter
pendent et leurs parents écartelé les
pour passer le temps sur plâtre du
ministre de l'intérieur ce grand artiste
a été condamné à une amende avec sursis
dans ces conditions pourquoi se priver
nick conrad c'est son nom a donc
récidivé ces jours ci avec un nouvel
opus dossier au niveau je baise la
france jusqu'à l'agonie jeu brute de la
france
je vais poser une bombe sous son
panthéon à la fin du clip il étrangle en
gros plan une femme blanche
vous avez raison est allé chercher ses
contenus monsieur le sénateur qui sont
aujourd'hui absolument inacceptable sur
les contenus haineux sur le terrorisme
sur la pédopornographie
nous devons aller plus loin et unir nos
actions avec nos partenaires européens
car sur ce sujet sans union pas de
protection efficace des français et des
européens donner de la force de
protection monsieur le sénateur c'est
aussi cela l'enjeu écologique du
week-end prochain
on en revient toujours à cette question
du retrait de la régulation des contenus
haineux en ligne on voit la france
toujours finalement dans la difficulté
face à ce phénomène
oui mais c'est un phénomène qui n'est
pas franco-français sita phénomène
mondial des réseaux sociaux permettent
de diffuser à très grande échelle et
très vite tout propos tout arty
toute fausse nouvelle et c'est bien le
modèle économique d comment dirais-je de
ces plateformes qui le permet pas ce que
diffuser quelque chose qui est
sensationnel qui va porter lieu à
polémiquer bien ça fait du clic ça
génère la tension les internautes et
donc plus la clique puis ça fait
d'argent de recettes publicitaires etc
si tu as donc c'est un modèle qui
devient rentable d'où le vrai sujet qui
est la question de la rentabilité du
modèle économique pardonnez-moi des des
plateformes maintenant des tels propos
sont infiniment condamnable bien entendu
chacun dira le crâne selon chacun peut
s'en s'en émouvoir et je pense que il
faut se poser la question comment est il
rendu possible que de tels propos
puissent tête voilà diffusée face à tout
à chacun
est-ce qu'il faut interdire son clip est
justement un ce rappeur salon toute la
question est celle de la liberté
d'expression en france il ya le principe
de cette liberté d expression conférés
par la loi de 1881
mais il y à la diffamation il y a là des
propos qui sont éminemment condamnable
l'incitation à la haine et ça ça mérite
d'être regardée de près voire d'être
jugé une dernière question 82e puisque
le sénat vient d'adopter le projet loi
pour une école de la confiance après
l'avoir profondément modifié à ce que la
version issue des travaux du sénat vous
semble satisfaisante est de nature à
calmer la grogne des enseignants
elle est alors grande des enseignants
grotte des élus puisque nous sommes au
sénat les collectivités territoriales
sont très concernés par cette loi
notamment puisque elle instaure la
scolarisation obligatoire dès 3 ans sont
les collectivités territoriales qui
scolarise les enfants créent les
conditions de leur accueil
nous avons très largement amélioré le
texte de remanier certains aspects à
certains égards d'ailleurs le ministre
s'est félicité du bon travail de la
chambre haute et a reconnu l'utilité du
bicamérisme nous avons été attentifs aux
inquiétudes des collectivités justement
des enseignants aidés et des parents et
nous avons fait un gros travail avec ma
collection le rapporteur l'ensemble des
groupes pour la faire progresser le
texte c'est le sens de la démarche que
cas toujours le sénat eh bien merci
beaucoup à catherine morin desailly d'or
était notre invité c'est la fin de cette
édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité politique
et parlementaire on va plus loin a
présenté par rebecca fitoussi très bonne
sur des programmes sur public sénat
retient de nantes
[Musique]